I gotta assume that there's some people
at the league who they enjoy the the
banter of the fan engagement and kind of
forward thinking and there's some people
who are probably more old-school just
like hey we got it and everyone else
stay out of our job 1,000% what option I
mean you anytime you did them with a
legacy system there's always gonna be
people that are like look if we just do
it our way it'll always work you know
and then there's obviously some upstarts
that are gonna be within the ranks
they're like hey you know maybe maybe
that guy's on to something so I know
there's a some controversy within that
and some going back and forth within
that for me I mean nothing that I do is
designed to harm the league in any way
like obviously why would I you know
start playing basketball three four
years old wanted to do nothing else for
playing the NBA why would I try to then
like take down the NBA while I'm only
six years in and potentially have like
another what seven eight years to play
or something like that you know this
there's always been about enhancing any
any additional structure it's been about
like engaging the fans because in the
end of the day like the fans as we see
are the most important piece of the
ecosystem if you guys watch you know we
still have a job we still have a you
know a league a a system of being an
ecosystem but if you guys don't watch
then we might as well be playing in the
park I mean it'd be a lot of fun but
we'd also have to get a day job yeah
what do you think kind of the fan
relationship looks like coming out of
quarantine right do you think that games
end up getting played with no fans in
the stadium or do we kind of wait told
they can come back like what does that
look like from where we're sitting today
and kind of end of May of 2020 I mean
with the immediate proposal really on
there there's no there's no way that's
gonna be fans you know with finishing
this season and I'm just playing
obviously these playoffs and and trying
to get a true into the 2020 season
there's no where they could do that with
fans such a condensed time I think 2021
we'll see what that brings if there's a
lot of headway on a vaccine or we just
have a lot more knowledge based on you
know what this virus kind of means and
its implications then I think we will
see fans return I mean
no that's what the owners are pushing
for and what the league collectively is
pushing for yeah whoever ends up winning
whatever that ends up meaning for the
2020 final season here is there an
asterisk next to that win like because
it wasn't a regular season do people
kind of look at it differently 1,000%
and you gotta remember like an ash tree
doesn't necessarily mean good nor bad
you know it just means different I know
and we could take like let's say the
front worker for example will take the
Lakers right LeBron will have won
another championship he's on a quest to
you know try to usurp Jordan is you know
the the goal or the most Dominator
whatever call it Jordan fans will say
there are no that championship shouldn't
count it was a weird season you know the
quarantine stuff and then they play at a
neutral site and so it wasn't near as
tough is Jordan going on the road and
beating the Jazz and the shot all that
stuff but then LeBron fans will say well
because he had to deal with all this
stuff and because he had to go through
all these things it makes him it makes
that championship better you know he had
to deal with you know Kobe's passing in
the turmoil of the league and the
quarantine and being off for so much
time and he came back and he was or
wasn't rusty and all the other stuff so
when I when I put out that comment about
the Astros I was merely just saying it
causes more controversy than debate I
wasn't saying it was either good nor bad